A diferencia de lo que sucedió en
primavera pero especialmente en verano
del año pasado los habitantes de la
ciudad de saporilla donde nos
encontramos están pudiendo disfrutar no
solamente del río nieper sino de los
parques que hay en la ciudad y del buen
tiempo una buena parte de la población
de esta ciudad de 700.000 habitantes
antes de la guerra ha regresado y lo que
se ve en las calles es bastante vida con
los restaurantes y con los bares
abiertos Como sucede en el resto de las
ciudades que no están en medio del
conflicto en Ucrania pero a diferencia
de ciudades como kiev o comodesa por
ejemplo que están alejadas del conflicto
la situación en saporilla es bastante
diferente Esta es la capital de una de
las cuatro provincias que fue
ilegalmente anexada durante ese
referendo realizado el pasado septiembre
por Vladimir Putin y más del 60% de esta
provincia se encuentra en poder de las
fuerzas de Moscú no muy lejos de aquí a
las poblaciones cercanas son ya un
frente de batalla y también tiene otro
punto especial y es que muchas de esas
poblaciones son totalmente atacadas
durante el día y la noche porque aquí es
uno de los lugares donde se espera que
se realice esta contraofensiva que
debería empezar en los próximos días y
semanas pero mientras que en esas
regiones de saporilla están altamente
militarizadas con muchas nuevas brigadas
y batallones desplegados por el sector
hay lugares que están totalmente
militarizados aunque las fuerzas
ucranianas siguen guardando el
secretismo de lo que sucede en ese
frente de batalla la situación en la
ciudad como decía es totalmente
diferente la vida ha regresado es
tempranas horas en la mañana pero ya hay
gente pescando y cuando cae la tarde
estos bulevares están llenos no
solamente de personas sino especialmente
niños que vienen a disfrutar